"It sounds like your battle to sever immortality with Kuro
Is near a conclusion. You killed all those who
Interfered" "I did." "I see, you did well to kill without hesitation
Don't forget Sekiro hesitate and you lose, that is the way of war"
When he was young Ishin fought desperately
Spending his days in pursuit of life-or-death combat and from each enemy
He conquered he took something of their style polishing his arts in the blood of his enemies
Ichimonji, the recognition that posture is a samurais
most treasured trait Ashina cross an art devoted to the swift
unindulgent kill and perhaps most importantly there was one mind which requires the user to
Focus their entire soul on the release of their blade because for all of his ruminations on swordplay
Ishin's blade always moved first, he stopped at nothing in his search for strength and the single-minded focus
Ended with him taking back Ashina for his own
It attracted a ton of people to his cause even prominent bandits like Gyoubu Oniwa
who when he was defeated by Ishin
Actually accepted the offer to serve in his army, and when they crushed the Tamara clan and cemented the Ashina within the land
Ishin remembered those who fought by his side he gave Gyoubu the spear of the general he had defeated and
He also made him retainer to the young lord Genichiro
Ishin's adopted grandson who would eventually lead the Ashina in the years to come
"Genichiro, forgive, me
Ahh."
Later in life, the elderly Ishin was more akin to a sharpened blade
His steadily honed techniques had culminated in the Ashina style
Soundly, eliminating all wasted or idle movement "The ways of the Ashina blade
It's our school of fighting but there are no hard and fast rules. You just win your battles
that alone is the most important roar of the Ashina style" with a clan that reveres him and
Many who follow in his footsteps
He is a master who took the spirit of his craft to its pinnacle a true Sword Saint
Yet all things come to an end and with Ishin aging and ailing
the interior ministry finally saw their chance to move against the Ashina once more
"We managed to drive them back once, but the Interior Ministry's Army is far too powerful
Look at this mountain of bodies Ashina cannot be defended by normal means
Not anymore"
Genichiro Ashina now faces the overwhelming forces of the Interior Ministry
This faction that's poised to reunite all of Japan. It's an enormous responsibility
given the end of days that the Ashina now faced and it's this pressure that moves him to kidnap the divine heir and
and leave his Shinobi dead in a ditch "and that is why you wish to use the power of my blood
It doesn't matter how much power you obtain
You'll keep on fighting until you're a monster
Incapable of feeling pain or fear. I do not wish to corrupt the lives of men"
Curiously Genichiro is not grandson to Ishin by blood instead, he was adopted
Born a peasant and taken in by the Ashina after his mother's death
"Ashina, this land is everything to me, for her sake
I will shed Humanity itself"
The way he refers to the land it's almost as if it took on his mother's role after her death
As a result he would turn to all manner of heretical arts in order to better fight on her behalf
It's likely for this reason that he learned the Lightning of Tomoe
"What exactly is the Lightning of Tomoe?"
"Haha, that is a technique belonging to Genichiro's mentor. I'll wager it was quite the sight."
"His mentor?"
"Tomoe"
Tomoe was of the Okami a warrior from a divine realm who descended to the lands of the Ashina
"There aren't many masters of the sword like her, to see her fight, it's like she's dancing
When you look into her eyes
You feel as if you're being drawn into the depths of the ocean.
I was completely taken by her and it almost killed me. I have lived a long life
but that was the closest. I've come to death"
she was here to sever the immortality of another divine heir like Kuro and
While she was here
She made this really notable visit to Senpo
Temple in search of their red mortal blade the red mortal blade
It is said can bestow the gracious gift of Tears, which is the first step in severing immortality
however, it seems she never found it and perhaps
resorted to a cruder black blade instead
a blade named "open gate" that can also bring the dead back to life a blade that
May be not so surprisingly ended up in Genichiro's hands many years later
Genichiro once faced you without fear even though you are undying
Just hoping to wear down your resolve and win you to his side with sheer strength
However, when that fails it's these mortal blades that Genichiro eventually feels he must resort to in order to kill you
and in order to extract the dragon's blood from Kuro "The Crimson mortal blade. That means the one that he has
Must be black then, to abandon oneself in search of strength how tragic" meanwhile
Ishin is fighting a war of his own
Sickness is taking its toll as the interior ministry have their ear pressed to his door
Just listening for the first sign of weakness that could indicate the right time to strike
So he disguises himself as the Tengu freeing himself from his identity
Leaving him able to hunt down the rats that are infiltrating his home. "Who are" "hmm?
Ministry rats they find a way in through every crack and crevice
There's always more of them to kill" but this approach
Cannot last long "Lord Ishin, I'm concerned that the Tengu will make another appearance"
"Emma."  "Yes?"
"I Imagine Genichiro will show up eventually
to put it to use
The other mortal blade"  "To protect Ashina he'll abandon everything about who he is
won't he?"
"Yes
I expect no less from my own grandchild"
When Ishin draws his sword he focuses on his own soul on the self
Yet when Genichiro draws his he draws it for his country
His motivations are rooted in his childhood trauma of peasantry
Losing his mother and then being saved by what he sees as the country of Ashina
it's admirable to an extent but his
Nationalism ends up being his fatal flaw and it costs him everything
For a country is made up of its people and the man at its head sacrifices his humanity to keep it alive
Ironically if he had not then you and Kuro may have fought on the Ashina's behalf
instead of against it by antagonizing you and Kuro
He brings death to Gyoubu defender of the castle gates and hundreds of Ashina's own soldiers
He neglects his duties by going all in on a search for immortality
When it was his country that needed him most in the end Genichiro is forced to accept that
Ashina is already dead and
The only thing that's possible now is to bring it back to life
"In the end, I was powerless
Grandfather wasn't
Ashina will rise once more
with dragon blood searching through her veins
With this, Ashina's long night comes to an end
"Pitiful grandchild this was your last wish
To see Ashina returned from the great beyond
Which means Sekiro
I must destroy you"
One who returns from the great beyond does
So at the peak of their prosperity Ishin coveted strength and all manner of techniques throughout his mortal struggle
Hesitation is defeat I told you that didn't I?
"FACE ME SEKIRO!"
He wished for war until his final hour
"Do it! Finish this!" and that is precisely what he got. "Take my head!"
"Well done Sekiro farewell"
Before I end this video I want to show off the Sennheiser PC 37 X. Its this really good budget headset
That's currently $30 off if you use the link in the description
And it's a product that was already recommending to friends even before drop reached out to me
I used to use drop dot com way back when it was still called mass drop and I always liked their
collaborations with big brands because they tend to clean up their designs and
Also offer a cheaper price on top of that this clean matte black headset is no exception
So first up it has an open back design
Which I personally prefer and use over closed back headphones open-back headphones prevent heat buildup
they afford a more natural sort of sound which is great for editing and
You can actually hear sounds that are around you while you're gaming or listening to music
Since I've been playing Demon Souls all week
There were moments in game in Latria in particular
Where having good surround sound just saved my life being able to track enemies behind me
And also if you want to adjust that volume the headphones also come with a volume slider on the right ear cup
Which is something you'll come to swear by once you've gotten used to it
One thing that does usually bother me with headsets is that they often skimp out on the microphone quality
Because usually if you think about it, it's your friends hearing the Microphone. Not the user. So
Manufacturers often let it slide
however
One of the best selling points of these headphones is that the mic quality is way better than its competitors at this price point
Which as you can hear now has lots of body and a detail to it that is only enhanced by the inbuilt
Noise cancelling the PC 37 X punches way above its weight for the price point
So check it out in the description below if you're in the market for this kind of thing
Thank you to drop for sponsoring me and letting me try my hand at being a tech Youtuber
It was actually a lot of fun filming something completely different like this. So I appreciate the opportunity
Thank you for watching and we'll see you next time